breaking news in a landmark case a woman
in Germany has been sentenced to nine
years and three months for crimes
against humanity Nadine K was found
guilty of enslaving a 22 year old yazidi
woman for five years during Islamic
State's activity in Syria and Northern
Iraq it's one of the first cases of its
kind against former members of the
militant group let's talk to our Middle
East correspondent Aleister bunkel who
has the very latest for us from Germany
a really significant case Alistair
yeah very significant case
um Germany sort of leading the way in
many respects in charging former members
of Islamic State this trial started in
January but the verdict was handed down
within the last half an hour or so the
defendant found guilty of a list of
crimes uh against her including crimes
against humanity war crimes aiding and
abetting genocide but the key witness
has been a young yazidi woman as you say
called Naveen who was held captive by
her and her husband in various places in
Iraq and Syria during Islamic States
um some dominance over that period of
that region she was enslaved in that
house she was tortured she was sexually
abused she was pressed to try and change
her religion and kept in the most
horrific conditions we have spoken to
her in the last couple months we spent
quite a lot of time with her near her
home in Northern Iraq and up until this
point she's had to remain anonymous as
the trial has carried out its course but
we can now play for you a bit of what
she told me in an interview about what
she went through
SD
thank you
[Music]
so Naveen was kept captive for around
five years she only managed to escape
when she made herself known to a
Scottish documentary filmmaker in a
prison camp in Syria she was then able
to be released she returned home to her
husband who had waited for her hoping
that she'd be alive all this time and
eventually was reunited with him they
were both in court today Naveen sat in
the court barely 10 meters away I would
I would estimate from her Capital
listening to the verdict being read out
the her Captain Nadine was
hands-classed trembling as she heard the
Fate that awaited her which is nine
months and nine years and three months
in prison in what has been a landmark
case against a former member of the
Islamic State group